never seen our side publicly
bait the chinese and attack them
and presumably what secretary blinken
thought would happen is the chinese
would act to contrite
that they'd been chastised but instead
they went on counter-attack
talked about the slaughter of blacks
inside the united states
made a number of charges against us that
were not qualified to criticize china
this is really a strong china that
thinks it's surpassing us
either now or in the near future and
they're willing to bite back
michael pillsbury there talking about
the meetings with the chinese in alaska
let's bring in our panel for the friday
lightning round charles hurt
opinion editor for the washington times
morgan ortega is former state department
spokesperson
and harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment
inclusion capital morgan this is right
up your alley uh your thoughts on that
china meeting and what we saw
well this just doesn't happen bret and
these sort of diplomatic meetings
i describe this to someone today as
basically the version of a diplomatic
bar
fight when you have these sort of
meetings they are carefully
uh choreographed and what was supposed
to be two to four minute remarks from
each side turned back it turned into an
hour
back and forth and so i i will say that
i i praised
secretary blinken last night for what i
thought was very appropriate words both
at the beginning and the end how he
stood up for our country
but the thing that concerns me brett is
in the obama administration we had a lot
of
really great rhetoric we had a lot of
stuff like crimea is ukraine
yet we never armed the ukrainians to
actually fight against the russians and
so
what that means is are we going to
continue to have strong
rhetoric against russia and china from
the uh
biden team that was the obama team but
without the credible threat of force
these countries know it to happen and i
would just end by saying
i was very proud to work for mike pompeo
last night because that never would have
happened to him
well speaking of which your former boss
tweeting out
strength deters bad guys weakness begets
war
charlie yeah well it was pretty
extraordinary to think that
the united states would get a lecture
from the chinese about
human rights violations but honestly if
you look back at it you know accusing
the americans of being racist
a lot of it is the kind of stuff that
we've been hearing in our own political
process
uh for the past two year year and a half
uh from president biden and from
from democrats so it's kind of hard
almost hardly surprising
but shocking to have this spill out like
that
on on the national stage and then to
have president biden later today
come back out and basically kind of echo
what the chinese were saying by
basically accusing americans of being
racist again uh by
uh for being concerned about where the
the uh
where covet 19 originated which was in
china
um and so so it really is quite
extraordinary and i
i can't help but think uh that morgan is
exactly right we wouldn't have seen this
for
under a president trump at the very
least you can't
say anything other than the fact that
you know china and other adversaries
they had no idea what president trump
was thinking at any given moment
they didn't know uh exactly how to
handle him
and i think that was probably a far
better footing for us
than the current one all right harold
quickly on this i want to get to winners
and losers
well the theater we saw in alaska was
was exactly that i hope we realized that
and remember that the 20th century was
our century the american century
and the 21st century will be ours if we
harness and develop the technology and
innovation to winning ai
breakthroughs in ai and biotechnology
and medical research
that's our key that is the key to
unlocking the growth and the insurance
that we will win
and that america will indeed again call
this century our century
all right this is our time to do
lightning winners and losers harold
first
uh my winner is twofold it's president
trump for urging every american
including
many republican men to get the vaccine
he did the right thing and and president
biden for developing a distribution
package that works for everyone and our
loser is hate there's nothing wrong with
disagreement in politics and in life but
when it escalates and spreads to
destruction and violence
it's the kind of hate that we can't live
with and we should all do better
to try to stop all right morgan winner
and loser
winner i'm going with congresswoman
maria salazar a freshman
a hispanic woman from florida she came
out with an immigration plan this week
not all republicans or democrats are
going to agree with it
but i see a republican superstar on the
rise she checks all the boxes
she's very smart very savvy so she's my
winner loser
governor cuomo i mean he's a grandma
killer and he harasses his staff um
i think that's enough said all right
charlie bring it home winner and loser
uh a winner is china they couldn't pay
for a better uh
adversaries in in in our political
government right now
than they've got uh loser is the
american taxpayer who just had a 1.9
trillion dollar check written in their
name uh that they'll
never be able to pay off in their
lifetime for a bunch of stuff that
didn't have to do with covid
all right guys have a great weekend
thanks when we come